Vad är det stora problemet hos alla LinkedIn-riddare i dag som säger att de är duktiga chefer?
Men är det inte?
För så får jag säga att det måste vara ett helt gäng jätteduktiga chefer.
Ja men skit i dem nu, det är ingen bra content.
Make Sweden stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag är ju, kan det inte ta?
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rejändes bra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta men, jag säger, jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Välkommen till podden Make Sweden stronger, där vi intervjuar lite entreprenörer och allmänt löst folk som är framgångsrika inom någonting.
Och lyssnar ni på podden så gå in och släng en rating eller en like.
Vi har en tråd på LinkedIn som jag har skapat med de andra e-handelspoddarna och för att jag ska kunna skryta i den podden om att vi är bäst så måste jag ju också vara bäst.
Så, gå in och röjta.
Idag har vi Annika med oss från Rapunzel och Annika är den gäst som jag har jagat under längst tid för att ställa upp i podden.
Jag tror att jag har skrivit till dig fyra eller fem gånger och blivit vansinnigt knobbad.
Så kul att du är med här till slut.
Tack så jättemycket.
Jag tycker att det är jätteroligt att vara med och när jag knobbar så är det bara för att jag är lite nervös för såna här situationer.
Men nu så.
Ja, fast du svarade ju.
Nej, jag vill inte vara med i din podd.
Nej.
Jag tycker att det ska bli faktiskt jävligt kul.
Jag har ju, jag älskar att ha med folk där, dels älskar jag att ha med folk där jag har ett intresse av branschen, men sen älskar jag att ha med folk där jag inte kan någonting alls om branschen och du har ju jobbat i båda de branscherna kan man säga.
Du har ju varit vd både på Stronger som, vad ska man säga, jag är inte i samma bransch men jag har ju koll på det området.
Och nu är du på Rapunzel som ligger så långt ifrån mig som du över huvud taget kan, så jag tycker att det är fruktansvärt spännande att ha det här idag och bara få fråga ut ett tag.
Hur tänker du själv kring, kan man hoppa bara som vd mellan olika bolag i så skilda nischer?
Ja men det tycker jag att man kan.
Dels så kan man ju både se det som olika branscher mellan träningskläder och hair extensions, men man kan också tänka att det är samma bransch, att man jobbar med e-handel, Direct-to-consumer, digital marknadsföring, CRM och så vidare.
Så att det bara är produkten som sker.
Men för mig så var det jättespännande att byta produkt.
Jag älskar träning, jag har jobbat med träningskläder på Stadion, på Rönish, på Stronger.
Det var dags för mig att ta tag i en annan produkt.
För mig så betyder det i alla fall att jag gick från att vara superengagerad och superkunnig på själva produkten till att lägga mitt fokus på lite andra delar av företaget.
För här är det absolut inte jag som är bäst på produkten, det är andra personer som är det.
Men var det det som var en av anledningar till att du bytte?
Var det för att du ville liksom komma in i en bransch där du inte kunde någonting eller blev du headhunted?
Jag jobbade i styrelsen.
Så att jag jobbade som DTC och e-handelsexpert eller hade den rollen i styrelsen.
Det var egentligen ganska mer organiskt.
Den förra vd-rollen går vidare.
Och jag hade den stolen framför styrelsen och blev frågad av mina kollegor i styrelsen om jag inte kunde ta uppdraget.
Det är lite smickrande.
Ja, absolut.
Och så spännande, det var precis rätt kombination av ett superetablerat, välkänt varumärke med en massa av utmaningar.
Så det tyckte jag var en bra kompon.
Blev det skumt, vad hade du för roll i styrelsen innan?
Var du ordförande eller var du en ledamot?
Nej jag var ledamot.
Var det skumt att gå från att vara en styrelseledamot till att plötsligt bli någon sorts rapporterande vd?
Och gå från den positionen till den positionen?
Nej det tycker jag inte.
Jag tyckte att det var spännande.
För dels tror man ju kanske när man jobbar i en styrelse att man vet väldigt mycket om bolaget.
Jag tyckte det var spännande att se vad jag egentligen visste och vad jag inte visste.
Och en del vet man ju väldigt mycket, vet man absolut ingenting om.
Och det tyckte jag mest var spännande att få uppleva.
Och sen så hade jag ett jätteförtroende för vår styrelseordförande, att han var bra och att han har varit vd själv, vilket jag tycker är superbra för mig som vd, i en vd-roll att ha en styrelseordförande som själv har suttit i den rollen.
Så att nej, det var ju nu bäst positiva förväntningar och det har känts bra, naturligt.
Det är ett bra gäng.
Du nämnde här, du var först på Rönnish, och sen var du på Stronger och nu är du på Raffunzel.
Det är lite olika resor, även om du sa att det finns lite likheter man jobbar med.
Det är ju inte jättelikt, ni har ju flera salonger nu i Raffunzel till exempel.
Stronger hade ju en ganska bizarr tillväxtresa under din tid där och Rönnish kan jag inte så mycket om men det känns som ett såhär, det känns bara som ett starkt varumärke som folk typ har koll på, som har koll på varumärken.
Alltså det känns bara som tre väldigt olika resor.
Hur har du liksom utvecklats?
Var du chefsmaterial från början eller är det något du har vuxit in i?
Har du liksom blivit en vd eller var du en vd när du satt igång?
Nej men jag tror det för att man vill växa in i oss, men jag har nog alltid varit chef.
Jag har varit chef sedan jag var 21 och jag kommer inte ihåg om jag har varit det.
Men jag har nästan alltid haft ledande rollar hela mitt liv.
Men sen har det varit mer det ena lätt till det andra.
Jag har inte någon supercarrieris tycker inte jag själv.
Det har gått lite till höger och vänster och satt lite små stigar och lärt känna saker på vägen.
Jag var absolut inte vd på Rönnish.
Jag jobbar som varumärksansvarig och hade hand om produkten, alltså tajsen och sportbhr, design och produktioninköp och så hade jag hand om varumärket och marknadsföringen.
Så det var mina roller där men det var väl också så att det hade också någon mentor som började se till med du är väldigt bred Annika, ska du inte börja som CEO i något bolag och börja nyttja och kanske ska du inte gå mot en vd-roll, du har bred kunskap, ska du inte nyttja det på något nytt vis och växa ytterligare och sådär.
Sådana råd har jag väl fått på vägen och sen har jag haft bra arbetsgivare som har låtit mig ta mig an mer och mer och prova mig fram.
Man behöver ju ha liksom, det är möjliggörande.
Ja för så var du väl på Stronger också.
Du kom väl, du kom ju inte dit som vd utan du kom väl dit som CEO.
Gjorde du inte det?
Ja, exakt.
Och sen fick du bara steppa upp i den rollen.
Vi ska inte fastna i Stronger för det är ju inte den resan du är i nu, men ni gjorde ju en helt surrealistisk tillväxt.
Jag tror att du kom in, rätta mig om jag har fel, men jag tror att du kom in när ni omsatte typ 40 miljoner och lämnade kanske när ni omsatte 300 någonting på några år senare.
Stämmer, vi var upp och vända över 400, så vi gjorde en tiddubbling.
Tyckte jag ändå var kul, men sen hade vi lite, sen tappade vi lite grann efter covid.
Vi hade ju så fina covid-effekter, det var ju så här hypertillväxt verkligen.
Men det stämmer, från 43 till, jag låter säga att jag lämnar på 350, jag kommer faktiskt inte ihåg vad det bokslutet blev, men det var ju jättetillväxt.
Vad är det för oss som aldrig kommer, liksom var med i en sådan tillväxtresa?
För då får man ju en massa artiklar som fan var bra, och allting är guld och grönskor.
Vad är det som är svårt under en sådan tillväxtresa som inte vi vanliga dödliga kan fatta?
Det är jättemycket som är lätt och roligt, ska man också komma ihåg.
För annars låter det lite klyschigt att bara lyfta.
Men, på tal om klyscher, så ser vi hur det är bra att det är en utmaning att bygga det här flygplanet samtidigt som det flyger iväg i full fart.
Det är känslan hur mycket klyschad den är att man springer efter företaget och försöker lappa lagar och bygga medan man bara flyger.
Jag kände som att, jag brukar säga till dem jag pratar mest med, det var som att få ett nytt bolag en gång i kvartalet.
Jag hade precis lärt mig hantera en storlek och försökt få in personal och tyckte att nu funkar väl ändå grupperna hyfsat här.
Så bang, så var det en ny storlek att hantera.
Och nya länder och allt som kommer med det.
Men det var ju sjukt troligt.
Utmanande är väl att lära sig den nya storleken hela tiden.
Jag tyckte att det var svåra val i att bygga organisation och management.
Ska man först gå på de här tillväxtpositionerna.
Jag vill ju bara ha säljande roller, marknadsföringsroller, influencer marketing och bara tänkte att vi har momentum i och var rädd varje dag och vakna av att vi inte hade momentum längre.
Och bara sa, har vi råd att ha en it-chef?
Råder ni in någonting?
Nej, det kommer inte att tjäna några pengar på en it-chef.
Vi tar en till på influencer marketing.
Lite sen kom jag till och med att man fick balansera upp det.
Men jag tycker att de prioriteringarna, de är svåra också när man har så sjukt stor tillväxt och momentum som man måste göra det allra bästa man kan av.
Men var uppstod liksom flaskhalsarna?
Flaskhalsarna i personal fick vi alltid tag i.
Vi var jätteattraktivt varumärkare och fick alltid tag i bra människor, det måste jag säga.
Värsta flaskhalsarna var väl en sak som förhindrade oss att växa ännu mer och det var väl produkter, vi hade ju alltid slut på våra bestsellers.
Det var väl en...
Vi var ju väldigt modiga, det är ju att göra en sådan tillväxträsa kräver mycket analys, snabba beslut och så mod i de besluten.
För jag tror det var fler e-handlare under den tiden som såg att det var en speciell tid att vara e-handlare i.
Men jag tror inte alla var lika modiga som vi var.
Men när du menar mod så menar du typ ta investeringar i lager och inköp?
Ja, och marknadsföring ska jag vilja säga.
Det är enorma investeringar i marknadsföring.
Men även om vi då investerar, ja, alltså på de procentella ökningarna, det var ju abnorma tal men trots det så räckte inte produkterna till och vi vågade inte vara ännu spänsterare än så.
Och vi kom ju också till en tid där det slog bakut ju, där varulagarna var för sura.
Men annars var det väl mest barotillförseln som kunde vara en flaskhals.
Det kommer inte på fler, vad tänker du på?
Fan jag vet inte, min e-handel växer med 20% per år, inte 150% så att...
hehehehe Fel person.
Jag brukar säga det, vi har den tråkigaste e-handeln i Sverige, den är extremt trappstegsaktig.
Men, men, hehehehe, ja det passar mig.
Men okej, jag skäper det.
Skulle du kunna göra någon sorts, vi behöver liksom inte dwell in the past, men sen när Stronger saknade in där, var det för att de hade tappat dig då, eller var det coronaeffekten som hade försvunnit?
För det har ju gått liksom lite neråt efter det.
Vad skedde, varför?
Folk köper väl träningskläder?
Ja, jag hoppas och tror att det går bra för Stronger, att man återhämtar sig fint.
Men det var ju, där var ju vi backade lite, som jag sa att vi började göra över 400 miljoner när jag var vd där också, och backade lite även då jag var vd där.
Men det vi möttes av, det var ju tufft med varulagret, till exempel att vi hade köpt på oss, inte orimligt mycket tyckte jag absolut inte, utan vi hade köpt mot den tillväxt vi hade.
Men den avstanna, jag tror att vi som är handelsbolag, vi och andra hanterar så många effekter som vi aldrig hade hanterat någonsin.
Det var ju att först skulle man hantera corona och förstå vad det innebär, sen skulle man hantera efter pandemieffekter och förstå vad det var.
Nummer ett så förstod vi inte på Stronger hur stora våra pandemieffekter var.
Vi tyckte att det följde vår kurva, vi hade haft en enorm tillväxtkurva i tre år innan.
Och egentligen var det bara att dra ut den tyckte vi.
Men sen in såg vi ju efter corona att vi hade ju levt för att både handen blomstrar och vårt produktsegment med activewear och loungewear så var det precis det man ville ha på sig i coronatider.
Så jag tror att vi slogs hårdare av effekterna efter corona än vad vi kunde föreställa oss.
Där fanns flera, barolaget bandit frukt mycket kapital.
Och sen så fanns det också lite sådana effekter att vi hade haft en unik position på Stronger med väldigt, väldigt printade tränningskläder och som satte oss på kartan.
Och helt plötsligt så skulle alla bara ljusbeja enfärgade kläder.
Och det, man ska säga, kan ju vem som helst, det gör ju alla.
Så det var väl lite olika saker som hände skulle jag vilja säga.
Fan, jag är så glad att jag inte är i en marknad som styrs av trender på det sättet.
Det måste vara hurrivelt att hela tiden behöva bara chansa typ.
Men har hår trender?
För bara så att folk vet om.
Rapunzel säljer, får jag säga typ, Rapunzel säljer lös hår och karsalonger.
Kan jag sammanfatta det så?
Det är väl jättebra sammanfattning?
Absolut.
Eller Hair Extensions kanske man säger?
Ja, det är samma sak, det är bara för olika språk.
Vi säljer massor av Hair Extensions, massor och massor, det är vår stora affär.
Sen har vi hårvård som stödjer våra hårprodukter, och sen driver vi salonger och en viss wholesale också.
Men finns det trender i det ni säljer?
Lite grann, jag tycker faktiskt att det är ett jättespännande sortiment nu när jag börjar lära mig lite om det.
Vi har ett enormt stort sortiment, vi täcker upp en massa behov och färger och texurer och grejer.
Man påstår gärna från oss och branschen att det finns mycket trender, men jag skulle säga att det roliga som jag uppskattar är att det inte finns mycket trender egentligen.
Vi försöker säga att nu är det modernt med lite värmare toner och så vidare och då kanske det ökar pyttelite.
Men svingningarna är små och jag tycker det är skönt.
Det värsta är att vi äter fast fashion oavsett om det är kläder eller vad det är.
Jag tycker det är mycket roligare att jobba med att ha ett superbra sortiment som täcker jättebra never out of stock.
Men att hitta lagernivåerna, omsätta lagret många gånger per år, jag tror att vi har sett vårt laga tio gånger om året, trots att vi har ett jättesortiment.
Jag tycker det är roligare att jobba med det idag, men jag har jobbat mycket med trender tidigare, så att ja, det finns trender i år, men för oss i alla fall så är det väl mer kommunikation än vad det är i verklig handel.
Hur ser sortimentet ut på det?
Jag bara intalar mig att det är en helt horribel mängd artikler.
Jag har en ganska stor familj, jag har sju systrar och det finns en massa barnbarn och jag har ju ungar och du vet, när vi ses som familj så är vi ju, ja, vi fyller ju ett område liksom.
Och då kan man ju tänka sig att vi ska ha samma hår, men det har vi ju inte utan vi, alla har ju olika toner och vissa har såhär tjockt hår och tunnt hår.
Hur funkar liksom hårbranschen?
Måste jag ha, det måste finnas många nyanser och så många tjocklekar, eller hur funkar det liksom?
Ja men det är ett galet sortiment på sätt och vis, och det är, man kan tänka sig också att det är helt galet att sälja det online dessutom.
Och det tycker jag är ganska kul.
Det är min nästa fråga, är inte det kort jag typ?
Jo det är det ju, men man kan säga enkelt förklart så har vi cirka 50 färger, och bara min ljusgrå nyans finns kanske i fem, sex varianter som man då ska hitta absolut rätt ton av.
Förlåt, det finns 50 färger, finns det nyanser under de färgerna?
Nej, det är 50.
Okej, 50, okej jag fattar, ja.
Så 50 nyanser finns det.
Det finns sju längder, det finns sju infästningsmetoder, det finns massor av olika texturer och lockar och vågor och grejer.
Så det blir ju en variantrikedom som är väldigt, väldigt stor för att det ska passa alla.
Och ska man vara premium och resultatet ska bli skitsnyggt, så ska man ha rätt nyans och det ska se äkta och naturligt ut, det är grejen.
Och det är ju svårt, för man tänker sig de här 50 nyanserna, så ska vi återge dem.
Först ska vi ta väldigt bra bilder i massa olika ljussättningar för samma färger, att vara samma all tid, att vara konsekvent.
Och sen ska kunderna titta på de här färgerna på lite olika skärmar och så blir det lite fel ibland.
Och så ska man förstå textur och festen och komplicitet och sen gärna hur man gör, för det tycker vi också i vår uppgift att vara så här do-it-yourself-brand.
Så det är en jättekompenserad produkt att sälja och det tycker vi är, för alla här är ganska peppade på det, jag tycker att det är lite utmanande och kul.
Lent krasst då, hur gör man liksom för att du sa här ja, hur man återger de bilder och är det så man gör, man visar det på en bild.
Det finns inget så här, man lånar hem ett kit med hår och sen, jag bara funderar på det, det måste vara en helt brutal returfrekvens på eller beställer man liksom två olika sorter.
Hur funkar kunden?
Dels så, vi ser ju att vi har kunder som köper två-tre närliggande färger för att verkligen bestämma vilken färg det är, så det händer, men vi ligger på, över året ligger vi väl på cirka 18 procent i returgrad, det tycker jag ändå är okej för den här typen av produkt.
Sen är vi avundsjuk på övrig beauty som kanske ligger på 1 eller 2 procent, men vi tycker att vi är på en bra nivå nu med cirka 18.
Men sen har vi också så här provtofsar, brukar jag kalla det, det är små samples där man kan beställa tre stycken, man beställer de tre närmaste och stämmer av.
Sen har vi också en kundtjänst som mer än någonting annat faktiskt sifter med kunden och hjälper dem med videosamtal.
Så man kan se dem.
Såklart, ja det är rimligt.
Att bestämma färg.
Det vill vi utveckla ännu mer för att självklart göra kunderna mer nöjda och få ner returnivån ytterligare.
Ja men det är jätterimligt.
Hur sårsa man hår?
Det finns vissa länder i världen.
Och hur sårsa man så många olika?
Ja och det gör man inte för det färgar man.
Man bleker och färgar.
Så att de länder som är störst, Indien är störst i världen på hår.
Vi handlar inte från Indien.
Och sen så är vi i Kina II, vi handlar från Kina.
Och det är jättevis lite olika filosofier kring det där.
Vi lämnade Indien en gång för att i templet där flickorna och tjejerna offrade håret, så fick de ingen betalning för håret, för att det var ju prästerna som suppar samman håret.
Och då var det ju någon annan, det var kanske prästerna då, som fick betalt för håret istället, för kvinnorna gjorde det som ett offer.
Och då vår varande ägare och grundare ville ändra på den idén och besökte sig till Kina.
För till Kina är allting en transaktion på alla nivåer, så där är det tjejerna själv som får betalt.
Och sen finns det ju H-marknader man handlar på, och det är som höttåget typ.
Och så köper man de stora bandels efter olika kvalitetsnivåer.
Det finns liksom en bransch med fem standardiserade kvalitetsnivåer man betalar efter och så.
Men vi köper ju mestadels då svarta släta hår som vi bleker ner och sen färgar till vård av.
Kan man göra det?
Man kan färga, ofta, de har ju väldigt svart hår.
Man kan bleka ner det till min råttblonda.
Ja, det kan man absolut göra.
Så den nyansen har vi också.
Råttblond heter den så.
Den heter Stone eller någonting sådär fint.
Granit.
Okej, och finns det en sån marknad på, för jag gissar att Sverige inte ens är i närheten av störst inom löshår liksom, men det säljs sådana mängder.
Löshår, är det liksom primärt riktigt hår?
Ja, det skulle jag säga.
Det finns en produktsyntetisk, vi har både och, men alla våra stor säljande produkter är naturligt hår för det är det man vill ha.
Och det är ju en jättebusiness i hela världen.
Den växer globalt sett, men vad man kan säga, för det blir alltid lite svårt för oss skandinaver med lite tunna hår som inte växer så snabbt, en liten enkel grej bara för att se det bättre framför sig det är att, där i Asien vi köper våra hår, där växer ett hår ut tre gånger så fort.
Som ett skandinaviskt hår till exempel.
Då är det lite lättare att föreställa sig att den avyttringen eller donationen av hår kanske inte är så plågsam som när våra små hår.
Finns det tekniker för att få håret att växa snabbare eller är det bara att man genetiskt har det?
Jag tror att de här geografiska skillnaderna måste vara genetiska.
Sen jobbar vi, det finns mycket serum i vår del av världen som bland annat många män använder sig av för att förbättra.
Det finns mycket supplement och så vidare.
Men jag tror att där vi köper våra hår, högkvalitativa och snabbväxande, så är det ju i genetiska betingelser.
Det är bara jävligt spännande, det är ingenting man någonsin reflekterar över i vanliga livet.
Visste du om allt detta innan, när detta var färskt för dig innan du hoppade in i styrelsen där?
Jag visste ingenting.
Men det är också en rolig del att få lära sig en ny produkt och en ny bransch.
Det är jättekul.
Förlåt, jag ska inte fastna i det här med hår men fan det är rätt spännande.
Är utfallet en mot en?
Om en person klipper håret, räcker det till en person?
Eller räcker det till flera personer?
Hur mycket räcker en klippning till?
Åh, långt för snöret, jag vet inte riktigt.
Är det inte standard att man klipper i 30 cm längder?
Jag bara tänker att det finns en branschstandard.
Det kan inte vara att man klipper 5 cm.
Vad ska du ha det till?
Vi jobbar i vår kortaste längde, 30 längd.
Vår längsta längde, 70 längd.
Tjejerna får mer betalt längre längder.
Men vad man kan säga är att vi med våra ganska tunna hår skulle gissa att en full hair bundle, eller vad det heter på svenska, jag skulle gissa att den ändå blir hårddelar till kanske tre svenskar kanske, att sätta i för att vi har lite andra tunnare hår här än vad man har i Asien.
Ja, det här är sjukt spännande faktiskt och lite oväntat så där.
Hur jobbar man kring, om man bleker, hur jobbar man liksom kring kemikalier och regler kring hår för folk ska ju gå runt med det där i håret?
Är det en känslig punkt eller är det så standardiserat i världen?
Nej, men det är egentligen samma som, jag jobbar väldigt mycket med textil, framförallt med sportmoder och där använder man ju också jättemycket kemikalier för att bearbeta bromulen eller vad det nya material man jobbar med.
Även där är det infärgningar och sen ska man få färgen att sitta och sen kan det vara andra treatments.
Där finns det lagar och regler på vilka kemikalier man får använda.
Samma sak är det för oss att vi har också regler att följa.
För att först använda så lite kemikalier som möjligt att man inte använder onödiga.
Men sen att använda de kemikalier som man får lov helt enkelt.
Och de finns ju till de här reglerna för att undvika allergier eller skador, utan det ska vara sånt som funkar bra på människan.
Jag måste bara fråga, finns det löshår för skägg eller?
Vi har en kund i Malmö.
En kund?
Han brukar lägga ut på Instagram.
Han förlänger en lång, lång fläta i skägget, och så en lång, lång fläta till det sista håret han har där bak på huvudet.
Ja okej.
Det går bort.
Om någon av er gör det så dubblar ni försäljningen av skägg.
Jag gillar det.
Ni jobbar ju med både e-andel och så har ni butiker och salonger, och sen sa du att ni jobbade lite med wholesale.
Jag vet att det här med Omni nu är jättetrendigt och alla pratar om det, men det måste ju vara skitjobbigt att behöva rådda.
Det är ju helt olika erbjudanden.
Det är ju, alltså salonger är ju, det är så fruktansvärt personberoende, och det är ju man ska schema lägga, och man ska krångla och folk ska komma in, och så ska du driva e-handel som är så extremt, vad ska vi kalla det då, om pengar, alltså processpressat då, du ska ju skära varenda marginalkrona överallt, så det är så olika områden kan jag tycka, är inte det, vad får ni val att göra så?
Ja, vad får vi ha det till?
Vi ska ju växa jättemycket här framåt tänker vi, och det kommer ju komma från e-handeln.
Fast det är intressant, ni öppnade en ny supershow-butik här för typ en vecka sedan, tror jag det såg du va?
Nej, vi öppnar, det var bara som vi var ut och gjorde på er, vi öppnar en ny, jätteså fin salong runt Styreplan den 27 augusti.
Men den ska jag inte sälja någonting.
Jo men vår salong, vi har fyra salonger, de omsätter kanske nästan strax under 30 miljoner.
Så det är väl fint, och de är lönsamma, så det är inga konstigheter vad det är.
Och Stockholm går väldigt väldigt bra, så den gör vi också med till flagship store, för de är lite eftersatta i utvecklingen.
Så nu ska vi investera i dem och få dem vara fina flagship stores.
Men man kan ändå säga lite enkelt förklarat, om våra salonger omsätter i rundartal 30 miljoner tillsammans, och vår e-handel i rundartal 150 miljoner, så är det 25 man som jobbar med e-handeln, och det är också 25 man som jobbar med salongerna.
Så Working Capital presterar ju lite bättre i e-handeln än i salongerna.
Men vi har ändå bestämt oss för, när jag kom in i bolaget så fanns det salongerna, så vi har ju bara bestämt oss för att de ska vara där ensamma, det är de, och de ska bygga varumärke.
Det gör de inte riktigt ännu.
Personalen är fantastiska, vi har verkligen legat oss i av att kunna det vi gör och hållit på många år, men investeringarna kommer vi att lyfta och göra det till lite härliga upplevelser för de som ska besöka oss, men det ska gå hand i hand och det ska fungera, men vi försöker ha det ändå som hyfsat få silosa, för att det är två olika verksamheter som kräver olika grejer.
Och sen har vi cirka 500 salonger också, andra som köper våra produkter, och lite e-tailers.
Jag fattar, okej.
För det är inte så att salongerna pumpar ut försäljning åt e-handeln, utan de är liksom som fristående salonger som jobbar.
Ja men däremot så tycker jag att de prémunifierar vårt erbjudande.
För vi är ju ett do-it-yourself-brand.
Vi är en av de få som säljer jättekvalitativa hårprodukter direkt till kunden.
Många andra varumärkare som vi sätter en ära i att vi säljer inte direkt till consumer, vi säljer via professionals på salong.
Men vi ser oss som en möjliggöra, för det är dyra grejer, så vi ser oss som en möjliggöra att sänka trösklarna av lite hårförlängningar, och gå direkt till sytkonsument.
Men sen tycker jag att salongerna är till för det.
Är det för att det är svårt att sätta i bra hår, eller är det bara för att man vill behålla premiumsänslan?
Jag vet inte, det är vissa metoder som är ganska komplicerade, som inte jag skulle klara själv, men sen är det flera metoder.
Vi är ju superstora på tejp till exempel.
Det är ganska enkelt när man vet vad man gör, men det blir ändå en lite mer premiumupplevelse när det går att göra det i salonger.
De klipper in, de färgar in, de gör det alldeles gorgeous.
Så jag tycker att det ger oss möjlighet att leverera två upplevelser.
Jag köper igen, men hade no offense mot alla på salongerna här, nu har jag ju pratits eftersom jag är i e-handel, men om det är 25 pers där och det är 25 på e-handel, lägger du 50-50 av din tid på de här respektive, eller kan du lägga tiden ut efter omsättning och vinst?
Jag lägger nu min tid betydligt mer efter omsättning och vinst.
Ja, jag bara, ja exakt, du fattar vad jag är ut efter här.
Ja, men det är också vad jag kan tillföra.
Jag kommer ju inte från, där finns ju de som kan frisör i yrket och kan salong och den typen optimering.
Det är ju inte jag bästa.
Och hur är det ni jobbar, är ni i Sverige eller är ni i Europa, eller hur ser liksom marknaden ut?
Vi är störst i Tyskland, det är våra största marknader.
Och sen är Sverige tvåa.
Sen är det de nordiska länder, Tyskland är ett, Sverige tvåa.
Och sen är vi stora i Norden överhuvudtaget.
Och sen har vi Holland på tillväxt, och sen lite andra små sidigländer, men det är väl de som har någon omsättning att prata om just nu.
Är det konstigt att flytta sig till, om vi tittar på Norrväga och Europa, är Sverige och Tyskland, är det stora skillnader i hår, eller är det först när man kommer ner, jag bodde i Portgalle ett par år till exempel, där har man ju ofta vågigt, inte kastanjebrunt, men liksom brunt så som man tänker, brunt hår, inte lite brunt hår, utan riktigt brunt hår.
Men är Tyskland som, behöver ni köpa in massa nya modeller varje gång ni går in i ett nytt land?
Nej, inte med de länder vi har valt.
Jag tycker det är jättetrevligt att man kan ha ett sortiment och kapitalisera på det på flera marknader.
Det betyder ju att vi väljer marknader lite, är ful, riskminimera.
För det är både lagret, men sen blir det också content och kommunikation, marknadsföring och så.
Vi gillar mer att lägga till marknader som stödjer våra befintliga affär än att skapa en ännu större variantrikidomen än vi har.
Tyskland är väl bara så att det är en annan viktning av färgerna.
De passar vår färgkarta perfekt, de passar våra texturer perfekt men viktningen ser annorlunda ut.
Fortfarande när man kommer till Frankrike, Spanien, Portugal, nu inte stora där men det beror på andra saker.
Men då blir viktningen ytterligare lite annorlunda, men vårt sortiment passar ganska bra.
Okej, jag fattar.
Vi snackade förut lite om hur, vad ska man säga, flaskhalsarna på Stronger, de hade ju haft en väldigt snabb tillväxt eller ni hade en väldigt snabb tillväxt.
Och här på Rapunzel så har ni legat extremt stabilt över typ fem år eller något sånt där.
Jag kommer inte exakt ihåg siffran där.
Men vad är flaska, eller vad är det som du säger att vi ska växa ganska mycket här framöver, vad är det som ska göra att ni växer framöver som ni inte har gjort senaste två åren?
Det är det som jag tycker när jag kom in och det som jag visste var en möjlighet, och varför jag tyckte att uppdraget verkar spännande.
Hur är det att stå sig till marknadshöjden och kundanskaffningen, hur ser det än ut?
Det var lite lite nya kunder och jag kände att online marketing-strategien kunde vara lite mer aggressiv och så där, både utifrån spend, taktik, content.
Så det var ju nummer ett, så det var ettan det vi gjorde, att ändra om online marketing.
Och när man då väljer att investera lite mer i det, så känns det naturligt att titta vidare på CRM.
Så sen så tog vi tag i CRM och där var saker att göra verkligen.
Och det här är ju en återkommande kund, den som liksom har till exempel 10 extensions.
Hon sätter om sig ta över 6 vecka och en annan metod var 8 vecka.
Så det här är ju nästan att vi skulle kunna skapa fina prenumerationstjänster.
Så här skulle CRM vara starkt.
Så vi börjar med en online marketing och får igång den kundans skaffningen.
Sen tittar vi på serien och gjorde om lite på den delen.
Och sen nu precis har vi lanserat en ny site.
Och det behövdes verkligen, det var flaskhals.
Siten var som en B2B-site.
För det var så mycket att läsa och ta till sig och avancerad, komplicerad.
Så då har vi byggt en ny site, det är fortfarande kvar att göra.
Vi har bara sett Hikils var veta på den och ska jobba vidare.
Men då är idén att sänka trösklarna och ha h-guider, färgguider och guida kunder fram till köp på ett bättre sätt.
Så det var absolut en flaskhals som vi har väntat på att få lov att ta tag i.
Vi jobbar vidare, vi ska göra det här till en väldigt bra skålbar affär.
Så vi kan växa på många marknader.
Då var det de här delarna som var flaskhals, men vi började komma igen, de blev ganska bra.
Om vi tar innan ni satt igång uppdatering 2.0 här då, om vi ska kalla det för det här.
Du sa att håret liksom sätts om var rättet i åttan.
Det är inte så att man bara ploppar löshåret lite längre upp, utan det slits ut efter sex veckor eller ramlar det bort.
Nej det gör det inte, det hoppas jag inte.
När man sitter om det, man tejpar om det.
Men då använder man inte samma löshår.
Jo, nu köper vi de finaste, dyraste hårkvaliteterna.
Så hur har du dem i ett och ett halvt år?
Du köper en ny tejp?
Ja, och removers och lite små tängar och sen så.
Ah okej.
Sen har vi ju rätt typ, det är dyrt det här att hålla på med.
Så vi har också rätt typ av hårvårdsprodukter för att man ska vårda sitt hår.
Herregud, jag är så glad att jag bara rakar allt.
Helvete vad smidigt.
Jag är jävligt glad att jag köpte en rakapparat här för jag tror 13 år sedan för 399 spänn och den har jag använt sedan dess var annan vecka för både skägg och huvud så att jag jag har inte riktigt det problemet.
Okej men man ska köpa in de här tejparna och hårvårdarna och alla tänger och allt sånt där.
Har ni sånt här prenumerationssystem nu på gång?
Eller vad menar du när du säger att nu har vi börjat få igång det?
Nej men vi har såklart automatiserade flöden via CRN.
Ja olika påminnelser.
Ja att det ligger olika typer av flöden beroende på vilken produkt du har och när du påminns och så vidare.
Det skulle man kanske kunna ta ett steg längre till nästan våra prenumerationstjänster.
Det är ju det vi har gjort.
Men varför har ni inte gjort det?
För vi har gjort så mycket annat.
Jaha okej, det är bara en prioriterings, jag fattar.
Nej men fair enough.
Men yes, okej så att få kunderna att bli återkommande under längre tid, det är det som är den stora.
Är det att de har droppat av för att de hamnar hos andra konkurrenter, eller är det att de bara helt plötsligt, äh, skitsamma, det är för krångligt att gå in och beställa och så.
Vad är det som gör att ni inte har haft dem som återkommande innan?
Jo, vi har kanske haft, men vi har inte fyllt på tillräckligt.
Vi måste ju fyllda på med ny kund för att få en återkommande.
Så jag tror att vi har haft och har många trodda kunder.
Vi är ett av de mest etablerade varumärkena i Norden och Norea Europa på produkter.
Men påfillingen av nya kunder som också sen kan bli våra återkommande, den har varit lite låg och den jobbar vi på att förbättra, borde då som jag sa, först online marketing och sen vidare in i serien.
Sen tror jag att man kan hitta kunderna ännu närmare till sig om man ökar serviceen och kanske också betalar lösningar på mer prenumerationstjänster.
Jag tänker när du kom in på Stronger så kom du ju in i en viss roll och du fick följa med in i det här tillväxtcaset och då var det, du sa själv att det är som att komma in i ett nytt bolag varje kvartal så det blir rätt mycket släcka bränder eller lösa akut situationer.
När du gick in i Rapunzel då var ju det redan ett etablerat varumärke.
Det här är ingenting som blev trendigt för ett år sedan eller två år sedan utan varumärket har ju funnits.
Och som du säger, det är väl gissningsvis snarare så att du kom in för att nu ska vi ta nästa steg här.
Hur var det att komma in och få sätta en strategi?
Det måste vara, det måste varit rätt skönt att bara helt plötsligt få sätta sig ner och bara här är de tio stegen jag vill göra de närmsta fem åren.
Det måste varit en helt annan approach.
Eller hur kom du in i bolaget?
Vad var, hur var de första hundradagarna liksom?
De första hundradagarna var också fulla med förbränning.
För jag kom in ett år, 23 var det väl då, i september.
Och då hade vi rätt många månader i år att gå åt.
Det var några av vikandet började tappa lite.
Det hade inget tillväxt och resultatet såg något äventyrat ut.
Så det var få månader kvar att lyfta det på.
Annars kan man gå in och bli lite soft som chef och lyssna in första sex månader.
Nu blev det inte det för att vi ville röda vad vi kunde på det året.
Men sortimentet finns ju och är stabilt här.
Det fanns tidigare, varumärket var välkänt och etablerat men man kanske hade glömt att fylla det med lite värden genom åren.
Att det började fyllas på hur man skulle uppleva den.
Men varkännedomen var hög.
Så var det som du sa, mycket som kändes så här sent att bygga vidare ifrån.
Men det gav jag så nog med att, nu gör vi den här planen och jag hade sett lite från styrelsen och tänkt marketing måste växlas upp, det måste vara flera nya kunder.
CRM givet för den här produkten.
Sen är jag i handen, jag tyckte rätt så bra att jag var så okunnig själv på Hair Extensions, så jag fattade hur svårt det var på den här sajten att orientera sig i den här ganska komplexa produkten.
Så det blir en dröm direkt att det här måste vi utgå från folk som kan så här lite som jag kan.
Då ska vi köpa nya kunder så ska de kunna orientera sig.
Men nej, men det är ju kul att kunna ta tag i ett sådant förändringsarbetet samtidigt som det är många delar som är väldigt fina och stabila och som finns på plats.
Hur funkar mandat att få...
Det är en ganska halvviskabel process att göra om hemsidor och CRM-system.
När man flyttar över grejer kan det ske mycket saker.
Det är inte du som äger bolaget utan du har flyttat över.
Jag pratar ju ofta med de som har startat bolaget.
Ni hade investerare i Stronger och ni har investerare här i...
Hur är det att jobba under en externa investerare som inte är i bolaget?
Hur bygger man mandat att få igenom sådana här förändringar?
Nej, man bygger på sitt eget och sin ledningsuppförtroende såklart och försöker...
Är de öppna för det här Annika?
Kom in här och kör nu.
Hur har det varit?
Jag tycker om våra ägare, grupp och styrelse.
Det hade varit jävligt konstigt om du inte gjorde det nu.
Det hade jag använt som reklam för avsnittet.
Det är konstigt, det är argestolt.
Men jag tänkte väl trots det, det är väl inte så att de bara säger att kör, det här lär vara som en kul idé, utan det handlar väl om att underbygga, varför det behöver ändras, så de vill inte att vi tar onödiga kostnader för bolaget.
De jobbar ju på att skaffa en fin avkastning på bolagen som de äger såklart, och det kan ju vara våra pensionspengar eller vad som helst som finns i den fonden, såklart att det ska växa.
Men jag tycker att det tillför ytterligare en sån här kul, vad ska man säga, utmaning och parametrar med att vara vd för ett bolag, att det finns där.
Och sen behöver det inte vara helt dåligt.
Jag har också haft eget företag och bara gjort det jag har känt för.
Men för mig, där jag går och står idag, så tycker jag det är ganska kul utmaning att tvingas verkligen identifiera.
Behöver vi göra det eller kan vi göra det på ett annat sätt?
Alltså behöver vi göra en förändring som kostar såna investeringar?
Om vi kommer fram till att vi behöver göra det.
Att jag klarar att underbygga det och göra en plan som känns som sträk och förstudier och riskanalyser och allt vad det är.
Så att styrelsen, ro i skälen kan säga ja till projektet.
Men det är inte helt fel att behöva gå igenom den processen.
Det tycker inte jag.
Jag tänkte fråga, tycker du att det är långsamt och trögt eller är det behagligt?
Nej, för att det är inte långsamt och trögt.
Det har gått jättefort här.
Det har krävts att man har gjort processen, har underlagen, men det har absolut inte varit långsamt och trögt.
Jag ogillar långsamt och trögt jättemycket.
Men det är det inte.
Men som sagt, det krävs lite förarbete.
Ja, jag tänker att du har gjort ett par, det här blir, du sa ju att du inte var så karriärsberoende här nu, men nu har du ju haft två rätt intressanta vd-roller.
Kan du ge lite feedback på andra vd-are och chefer?
Vad tycker du att de gör fel?
Vad är det stora problemet hos alla LinkedIn-riddare idag som säger att de är duktiga chefer?
Men är det inte, först får jag säga att det måste vara ett helt gäng jätteduktiga chefer.
Ja men skit i dem nu, det är inget bra content.
Hahaha, vad gör de för fel?
Vad tycker du när du hör folk prata om ledarskap och driva bolag och tillväxt och sånt där, vad är det folk missar?
Jag tycker att vd-rollen, det kanske att man ibland är förvaltande.
Självklart ska man förvalta det som förvaltar skall, men jag tycker att vårt jobb som vd, jag skulle aldrig ha en vd-roll som inte innebär att bolaget ska växa.
Så där kan jag bli förvånad och kanske då lite kritiskt till när man går in och jag bara förvaltar det.
Jag tycker att det ska hända något nytt, sen får vi komma överens med ägarna vad det är för nytt som ska hända, men antingen vill man bli mer lönsam eller så blir större tycker jag är jättekul, jag vet inte exakt varför, men jag tycker ändå det är en rolig utmaning.
Sen kan man ju bli mer premium om det är så man vill plocka hem lönsamhet eller vad man vill, men där ska finnas en skjus i det man gör.
Men det är ju min personliga, eftersom jag tycker det är kul.
Så skulle jag då titta kritiskt på andra, så är det ju just att man gör en så stor skillnad mellan entreprenörskap och vd-skap.
Den förstår inte jag riktigt.
Vad menar du då?
Ibland är det så givet att i rollen av en vd så endast förvaltar du, och i rollen som entreprenör så ändast...
Kan du ha någon vision?
Ja, jag tycker att det där väl spelar ihop och sen viktar vi det lite olika.
Om man inte gör det så skulle jag vara kritisk till då, om man nu ska rikta kritik mot vd-er, att ha en vision, gör grejer, alltså ha en idé med bolaget, komma överens med de som äger det såklart.
Men det tycker jag, att man ska ha en idé om vad som ska hända.
Får jag sätta dig på pottkanten då, för att fråga, vad är din vision här för Rapunzel?
Ja men det är ju verkligen, dels säger det att vi ska vara nummer ett, inte bara i var och märkets kändom.
Fan vi älskar att du inte ens tänkt efter, du bara kom, fan vad härligt.
Vi ska vara ett i hur mycket man tycker om oss, och litar på oss.
Och sen så ska vi vara störst, vi tror till exempel att vi kan bli störst i världen på e-handel vad gäller hair extensions.
Vi har så mättat sortiment, vi bygger bättre teknik och bättre lösningar.
Det kändes ju att vad stoppar oss.
Vi ska bli betydligt större än vad vi är nu, men framförallt så ska det vara baromärketskännedom över fullt med att man gillar oss och litar på oss.
Ja det är ni som är benchmark som allting jämförs mot.
Antingen köper man oss Rapunzel eller så är man såhär ah, man kompromissade.
Ja, så är det.
Jag gillar det.
Jag tycker att vi avslutar det Annika.
Stort tack för att jag fick, och jag kan tillägga faktiskt att det var inte bara att du till slut svarade på mitt LinkedIn-inlägg eller mina ex-antal LinkedIn-inlägg, det var att jag till slut hittade dig på ett event och jagade upp dig och skrek att dig har jag försökt få tag på några gånger.
Så det.
Det var underbart att ha med dig i podden.
Tack så jätte, jätte mycket för allt du vet.
Tack så jätte mycket.
Tack ska du ha.
Det var roligt att vara med hos dig.
Det här att hålla på med, det är också en rätt typ av h-bordsprodukt för att man ska vårda sitt hår.
Herregud, jag är så glad att jag bara rakar allt.
Ja, helvete vad smidigt.